poverty hurts I mean I don't like it and
I don't like that our academic system's
so corrupt so it's one of the most
important messages I have for
entrepreneurs is that failure should
inspire you to get smarter don't let
failure ever stop you you know use your
brain use your creativity and
unfortunately our school system says if
you fail you're stupid that is not true
so the lesson to young people is don't
take a job for the money take the job
for what you're learning and school they
compensate for a risk by telling you to
memorize the right answer so in other
words these kids leave young people like
you leave school thing oh if I know the
right answers then there's no risk and
it drives old guys like me crazy you
know if we learn from our mistakes
mistakes are opportunities to get
smarter be humble and take a look at
something you know Millennials are the
most highly educated they know all the
answers but they're afraid of doing
anything